Ucrania es el París Hilton de los países…
cada vez que se habla de ellos en los medios
suele ser porque ha pasado algo malo. Cuando
pensamos en Ucrania, pensamos en Chernobyl,
la Guerra con Rusia o el escándalo de corrupción
que casi lleva a Trump a su primer impeachment.
Y lo cierto es que la historia de Ucrania
es para echarse a llorar. En serio, si algún
día os echan del trabajo, os deja vuestra
pareja o os pasa cualquier desgracia… leed
algo sobre la historia de Ucrania o ved este
vídeo: seguro que os hace sentir mejor. Hablamos
del país más pobre de toda Europa. En términos
de PIB per cápita, los ucranianos son tan
pobres como los salvadoreños y los turcomanos.
Sin embargo, todo esto puede cambiar. Y estamos
a punto de ver el “momento de la verdad”.
En estos meses, el presidente de Ucrania tiene
el gran dilema del que depende el futuro de
su país ¿A qué me estoy refiriendo? Al
final de este vídeo lo vais a entender.
Pero… ¿Por qué Ucrania es tan pobre? Alguno
dirá: ¡Está muy claro! ¡Ucrania perteneció
a la Unión Soviética! ¡Tuvieron un pasado
comunista y ahora son pobres! Sin embargo
hay muchos otros países que también formaron
parte de órbita soviética y que ahora son
democracias prósperas y con buena calidad
de vida: Polonia, República Checa, Estonia
son hoy países prósperos, con unos niveles
de vida equiparables a cualquier país europeo.
Y, curiosamente, ahora Polonia y Chequia están
llenos de ucranianos. Ucranianos que vienen
unos meses a trabajar en la construcción,
por ejemplo, para volverse después a su país.
De hecho, casi el 12% de todo el PIB de Ucrania
viene de las remesas de dinero que les llegan
del extranjero. Se estima que más de 10 millones
de ucranianos trabajan en el extranjero…
aunque sólo sea unos meses al año. Y digo
“se estima” porque la mayor parte de la
economía ucraniana es informal. Pensad que
hablamos de un país que ahora mismo está
en guerra abierta con Rusia. Pero no, esa
no es la única razón por la que son tan
pobres.
Así que la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es
¿Por qué Ucrania es tan pobre? ¿Qué pasa
en este país para que, en 30 años tras haber
abandonado el comunismo, estén peor, incluso,
que cuando eran parte de la Unión Soviética?
Hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta pero
antes… antes vamos a hablar de Internet.
Los ucranianos lo saben muy bien porque están
acostumbrados a lidiar con hackers de todo
tipo ¿Y cuál es la mejor forma de protegernos
de un ciber ataque? ¡Exacto! Usando una VPN.
Una VPN como SurfShark VPN. Surfshark es una
VPN fantástica. No sólo nos protege de hackers,
bots de propaganda y virus. Además, permite
que podamos entrar en cualquier sitio de Internet
sin encontrarnos con esos mensajes de “esta
página está bloqueada en tu país”. Vamos,
que puedes visitar cualquier sitio web de
forma segura. Además, Surfshark tiene una
herramienta que se llama CLEANWEB que bloquea
todos los popups de propaganda, por donde
se cuelan más bots y cookies que no queremos
tener. Por si todo esto fuera poco, con una
misma cuenta de Surfshark podrás registrar
todos los dispositivos que quieras ¿Quieres
navegar con seguridad desde tu SmartTV? ¿Desde
tu móvil? ¿Desde tu ordenador? Puedes hacer
todo esto con la misma cuenta de Surfshark.
Y, por supuesto, tenemos un descuento de lujo
para todos vosotros que seguís VisualPolitik.
Si usáis el código “POLITIK”, con K
de VisualPolitik, tendréis un 83% por ciento
de descuento más 3 meses extra totalmente
gratuítos. Tenéis el link en la descripción.
No esperéis más y descargaros ya la aplicación.
Y ahora sí, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
EL CAPITALISMO QUE NUNCA FUE
Os voy a hacer una pregunta ¿Habéis oído
hablar alguna vez del avión ANTONOV AN-225?
Se trata del avión más grande del mundo.
Por cierto, que si queréis conocer todos
los detalles técnicos de este coloso volador,
podéis ver visitar el vídeo que hicimos
en nuestro canal hermano: Megaprojekts. Pues
bien, este prodigio de la técnica está hecho,
íntegramente en Ucrania. Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik,
Ucrania es uno de los 9 países del mundo
donde puedes fabricar aviones sin salirte
del país. Tienen toda la cadena de producción
aeroespacial dentro de sus propias fronteras.
Pocos países pueden presumir de tener tanta
tecnología. Pese a todo esto, Ucrania es
tan pobre como Turkmenistán o El Salvador.
Si todavía no estáis intrigados, os doy
otro dato: Ucrania tiene recursos naturales
de todo tipo: hierro, uranio y todo tipo de
metales. Además tienen uno de los terrenos
más fértiles para la agricultura. El llamado
CHERNOZEM o “tierra negra” es un tipo
de tierra que, por lo visto, es fantástico
para cultivar. De hecho, durante décadas,
Ucrania era el granero de la Unión Soviética.
Pese a todo esto, este país ha sufrido una
invasión nazi y una soviética. Durante la
época de Stalin, la población fue sometida
a una de las hambrunas más terribles de la
historia, el llamado “HOLODOMOR”. Y tras
la caída del comunismo, Ucrania era una de
las repúblicas más pobres de toda la órbita
soviética. Un país que además estaba dividido
en dos grandes grupos: los que hablan ruso,
que están en las regiones del este, y los
que hablan ucraniano, que están en el oeste.
Como os podéis imaginar, estas divisiones
van más allá del idioma. La población ucranianoparlante
quiere que Ucrania pase a ser una economía
de mercado que comercie con Europa. La población
rusoparlante quiere mantener una economía
centralizada y mantener los lazos comerciales
con Rusia. Todo esto explica que Ucrania NUNCA
haya tenido una transición real hacia el
capitalismo. Prueba de ello es que a día
de hoy, todavía tienen más de 3600 empresas
estatales. Y todo esto se ve perfectamente
en cómo privatizaron su economía. Pensadlo
de esta manera: el comunismo soviético se
basa en una economía gestionada por el estado.
Es decir, que todas las empresas eran estatales:
desde las grandes energéticas hasta la última
fábrica de chocolatinas. Por eso, el paso
más importante en una transición de comunismo
a capitalismo es privatizar casi todas esas
empresas. Por eso, tanto Ucrania como Polonia,
Estonia, República Checa o casi todos los
países de la antigua Unión Soviética tuvieron
sus procesos de privatizaciones en los años
90. Sin embargo, como siempre decimos en VisualPolitik,
el diablo está en los detalles. Para que
lo entendamos mejor, vamos a comparar las
privatizaciones en República Checa con las
de Ucrania. Si estáis suscritos a este canal
desde hace tiempo, ya conoceréis la historia
porque os la hemos contado más veces. Si
no estáis suscritos a VisualPolitik ¿A qué
esperáis? ¡Suscribíos ya y dadle a la campanita
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones!
Pero volvamos con nuestra historia.
Tras el fin del comunismo, el gobierno checo
calculó el valor de todas sus empresas y
lo dividió en vales. Vales que vendió a
los ciudadanos a un precio moderado. De hecho,
el 80% de los ciudadanos compró alguna de
estos vales, que más tarde se podrían canjear
por acciones de la empresa. Es decir, que
en el momento en el que el Gobierno subastara
la empresa de turno, tú podías hacerte con
acciones de la empresa fácilmente. A día
de hoy, casi todos los ciudadanos checos tienen
acciones de empresas checas. Todo esto explica
por qué República Checa es uno de los países
más igualitarios del mundo. Poca gente lo
sabe, pero Chequia es uno de los países con
menos diferencias entre ricos y pobres del
mundo. Superan, incluso, a los países nórdicos.
El caso de Ucrania es completamente distinto.
Sí, es cierto, el estado también vendió
vales de sus empresas a los ciudadanos. Pero
con una diferencia. Vamos a imaginar que somos
un ciudadano ucraniano en los años 90 que
trabaja en esa fábrica de chocolatinas de
la que hablábamos antes. El estado nos dice
que va a privatizar la empresa y que, por
el equivalente a 1500 dólares podemos comprar
una participación. Cuando subasten la empresa,
podremos canjear nuestro papelito por un paquete
de acciones. Hasta aquí todo normal ¿El
problema? El problema es que ese papelito
no vale nada hasta que no subasten la empresa
y la podemos canjear por acciones reales.
Y ese momento nunca llega. Pensadlo bien,
las élites que gobernaban la nueva Ucrania
eran las mismas que habían estado en el poder
durante la Unión Soviética. Sólo cambiaron
el nombre del partido: del Partido Comunista
pasaron a llamarse Partido Socialdemócrata.
Por lo demás, mismas caras, mismas ideas
y mismos intereses ¿Conclusión? Que tu habías
comprado un vale que no servía para nada.
Y en ese momento es cuando llega el oligarca
de turno. Un señor que podría ser, sin ir
más lejos, PETRO POROSHENKO (Quedaos con
este nombre porque va a ser importante más
adelante) Pues bien, el tal Petro Poroshenko,
o muchos otros como él, es un señor bien
conectado con el Gobierno que ha juntado un
dinero con amigos y familiares. Y este buen
señor nos llega y nos dice “mira, ese papelito
que tienes no vale nada y tu necesitas dinero...
¡Mira, te doy 100 dólares por él y, al
menos, puedes pagar tu alquiler este mes!”
¿Qué hacemos? Se lo vendemos. Y justo, cuando
el señor Poroshenko me ha comprado el papelito
a mí y a todos mis compañeros de trabajo
¡Sorpresa! El estado llega y subasta la fábrica
de Chocolates. En otras palabras, que por
muy poco dinero, Poroshenko se ha hecho con
la propiedad de una fábrica de chocolates
¿Os parece injusto? Pues así es como nació,
en 1996, el Grupo ROSHEN, que hoy en día
es el principal fabricante de dulces de Ucrania.
De hecho, el señor Poroshenko es conocido
como el “Rey del Chocolate”.
Pues bien, Poroshenko es un ejemplo de oligarca.
Para que os hagáis una idea, se calcula que
el 85% de la riqueza de Ucrania está en manos
de oligarcas. Podríamos decir que los oligarcas
son como el sueño americano… versión mal.
Son grandes empresarios que se han hecho ricos
gracias a los favores políticos.
Por ejemplo ¿Recordáis ese Chernozem tan
fértil para el cultivo? Pues casi todas las
tierras de cultivo de Ucrania están en manos
de 25 terratenientes. Y diréis ¿Dónde está
el problema? ¡Es el mercado, amigo! Pues
lo cierto es que no. Hasta hace poco tiempo,
la compraventa de suelo agrícola en Ucrania
estaba prohibida. Es decir, los oligarcas
se hicieron con las tierras durante las privatizaciones
y la ley les protege para que las mantengan
pase lo que pase ¿Conclusión? La agricultura
ucraniana es totalmente improductiva. Pese
a tener tierras hiper fértiles, el 70% de
la tierra produce la mitad por hectárea que
en Estados Unidos.
A todo esto tenemos que sumarle los escándalos
de corrupción en las empresas estatales.
Para que os hagáis una idea, la empresa más
grande del país es Naftogaz. Naftogaz es
la empresa de gas ucraniana, que pertenece
al estado. Según un think tank de Kiev, la
corrupción en esta empresa supone más de
3.000 millones de dólares al año. Y, obviamente,
toda esta corrupción se traduce en pérdidas
millonarias. Sólo en 2014, las pérdidas
de Naftogaz suponían un 6% del PIB Ucraniano.
En otras palabras: Ucrania es pobre en muy
buena medida por culpa de la corrupción de
los propios ucranianos.
Pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando muchos…
¡A ver, Fonseca! Ucrania está en guerra
con Rusia. Tienen regiones enteras invadidas
por Rusia ¿De verdad esto no tiene un impacto
económico? Pues sí. Y ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver.
EL MOMENTO DE LA VERDAD
A no ser que viváis en una cueva, todos sabéis
que Rusia y Ucrania son enemigos acérrimos.
Esta guerra empezó tras las protestas del
Euromaidan. Miles de jóvenes salieron a las
calles de Kiev a protestar contra el gobierno.
La policía les reprimió violentamente pero,
finalmente, lograron derrocar al gobierno
prorruso de Viktor Yanukovich. Lo que seguramente
no sepáis es ¿Por qué empezó todo esto?
Pensadlo bien, hasta el año 2014, la mayoría
de los ucranianos no querían entrar en la
OTAN. Por aquel entonces, Rusia era el principal
socio comercial del país ¿Qué ocurrió
para que la situación haya dado semejante
giro de 180º? Pues todo empezó por esta
noticia.
Ucrania suspende las negociaciones del tratado
de libre comercio con la Unión Europea y
Putin gana el pulso
Por resumir: hasta el año 2013, Rusia era
el principal socio comercial de Ucrania. Rusia
vendía su gas y Ucrania vendía sus metales
y sus cereales. Sin embargo, Ucrania no quería
depender tanto del Kremlin. Así es como empezaron
a negociar un tratado de libre comercio con
la Unión Europea. A finales de 2013, el Presidente
de Ucrania estaba a punto de firmar ese tratado.
Pero Putin le presionó para que se echara
atrás ¿Recordáis que os decía que Ucrania
se divide en dos mitades? Pues la mitad ucranianoparlante
entendió que el veto a este tratado era una
traición. Y así es como estallaron las protestas
del Euromaidan. Estas protestas sirvieron
para derrocar a Yanukovich. Y entonces, la
mitad rusoparlante se sintió traicionada
¿Cuáles son las regiones con más rusoparlantes
de todo el país? Crimea, Donesk y Luhanks.
Estas tres regiones querían separarse del
resto
de Ucrania. Rusia apoyó a los separatistas.
Y así es como estalló la guerra de Ucrania.
De todo esto hablaremos en profundidad en
otro vídeo. Porque hoy nos vamos a centrar
en la economía. Porque la primera consecuencia
económica de esta guerra fue el fin del comercio
con Rusia. Fijaos en esta gráfica.
Como podéis ver, a media que Ucrania deja
de comerciar con Rusia, empieza a comerciar
con la Unión Europea. A día de hoy, Bruselas
es el principal socio comercial de Kiev. Y
muchos pensaríais que esto era todo un nuevo
comienzo para Ucrania. Un cambio de rumbo.
El fin de la oligarquía prorrusa ¿Verdad?
Pues… lo cierto es que no ¿A que no adivináis
quién fue el siguiente presidente ucraniano
después del depuesto Yanukovich? Atentos.
El Rey del Chocolate, Poroshenko, gana la
presidencia ucraniana aunque la violencia
continúa
Habéis oído bien. Ucrania sustituyó a la
oligarquía rusoparlante… por la oligarquía
ucranianoparlante. Todo cambió para que todo
siguiera igual. Desde entonces, Ucrania ha
prometido un sinfín de planes de lucha contra
la corrupción. Han surgido varias plataformas
de la sociedad civil para llevar los casos
más flagrantes a los tribunales. Pero, a
la vez, las élites de Kiev han intentado
frenar muchas de estas propuestas. Así fue
hasta el año 2019 ¿Qué paso entonces? Ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver.
¿LIMPIEZA GENERAL?
¿Os acordáis del primer Impeachment contra
Trump? Si recordáis, todo empezó porque
Trump, supuestamente, prometió unas ayudas
militares a Ucrania a cambio de que abrieran
una investigación contra Biden. Corría el
año 2019. Y así es como el mundo conoció
al nuevo presidente ucraniano: Volodimir Zelensky.
“Me dirijo a Petro Poroshenko. Me has invitado
a un debate y pensabas que me asustaría y
me escondería. No soy como tú en 2014”
Vale, os pongo en situación. Imaginad que
Martin Sheen, después de interpretar el papel
de presidente de los Estados Unidos en el
Ala Oeste de la Casa Blanca, se presenta como
presidente de Estados Unidos… pero de verdad.
Pues ese es exactamente el caso de Zelensky.
Hablamos de un actor de televisión que se
hizo famoso interprentando el papel de presidente
de Ucrania. En el momento más dulce de su
carrera de actor, se presentó a las elecciones.
Pocos habríamos apostado por su carrera política.
Pero, contra todo pronóstico, en Mayo de
2019, ganó las elecciones a Petro Poroshenko.
Su mensaje era: no soy ni prorruso ni antirruso,
mi enemigo es la corrupción y los oligarcas.
Y eso explica que, bajo su gobierno, se hayan
aprobado medidas como esta.
El Parlamento ucraniano aprueba una ley para
abrir el Mercado del suelo agrícola que empezará
en julio de 2021
¿Recordáis aquellas leyes que blindaban
a los oligarcas ucranianos? Pues, poco a poco,
el Gobierno Ucraniano está cambiándolas.
En febrero de 2021, congelaron las cuentas
de otro oligarca prorruso, el multimillonario
VIKTOR MEDVEDCHUK. Todas estas medidas son
muy importantes para Ucrania. No sólo sirven
para limpiar el país. Además, son esenciales
para que puedan recibir ayuda internacional.
Por ejemplo, Ucrania ha pedido un préstamo
de 5.000 millones de dólares al Fondo Monetario
Internacional. Pero este préstamo sólo llegará
si Ucrania se toma en serio su lucha contra
la corrupción. Y por cierto, aquí tengo
que hacer un PARÉNTESIS. Probablemente no
veréis este tipo de noticias en un periódico
normal. Pero ¿Sabéis dónde podéis leer
análisis sobre este tipo de temas todas las
semanas? ¡Exacto! Apoyando a VisualPolitik
en Patreon. Desde hace varios meses hemos
lanzado una newsletter titulada “Las claves
de la semana” donde os informamos de este
tipo de temas que, son muy importantes, pero
que se quedan fuera de los grandes titulares.
Es decir, que no sólo estaréis apoyando
a VisualPolitik sino que además, recibiréis
más información y más análisis que difícilmente
encontraréis en otros medios. Hecho este
paréntesis, sigamos con la historia.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
en este momento: Zelensky debe ser todo un
héroe para los ucranianos. El hombre que
está haciendo justicia contra todos los oligarcas
¿Verdad? Pues lo cierto es que no. Zelensky
empezó su presidencia con unos porcentajes
enormes de popularidad. Pero en el último
año ha caído en picado. Es más, su partido
se ha pegado un auténtico tortazo en las
últimas elecciones municipales. Muchos pensaríais
que todo esto se debe al CoronaVirus. Son
malos tiempos para gobernar ningún país.
Pero recordad que estamos hablando de Ucrania.
El país del sueño ucraniano, que es como
el sueño americano… pero mal. Lograr el
éxito en Ucrania sin contar con los oligarcas
es prácticamente imposible. Y eso también
incluye a Zelensky.
Estados Unidos impone sanciones al oligarca
ucraniano Igor Kolomoisky por supuesta corrupción
Y aquí es donde llega el auténtico momento
de la verdad para Ucrania. Os preguntaréis
¿Quién este IGOR KOLOMOISKY? Pues nada más
y nada menos que el dueño de la televisión
donde Zelensky se hizo famoso ¡No sólo eso!
Es uno de los principales apoyos del actual
presidente de Ucrania. Tanto que incluso ha
sido su jefe de gabinete durante sus primeros
años de presidencia. En otras palabras, que
hasta el azote de la corrupción en Ucrania
ha necesitado a un oligarca para darse a conocer.
Y diréis ¿De que se le acusa al bueno de
Kolomoisky? Pues veréis, además de tener
una televisión, Kolomoisky era el dueño
de un banco, el PRIVATBANK. Este banco es
responsable de un fraude que ha costado a
las arcas del estado más de 5.500 millones
de dólares. Vamos, que hablamos de corrupción
a gran escala. Y este es el auténtico momento
de la verdad para Zelensky. Lo habitual en
estos casos sería que el Gobierno hiciera
lo imposible por salvarle de la cárcel. No
sería la primera vez que un oligarca ucraniano
sale libre de cargos de un juicio gracias
a sus conexiones políticas. Dicho de otra
forma: que Ucrania está viviendo un auténtico
dilema. El resultado de este dilema es clave
para el futuro del país.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Será distinto esta vez? ¿Permitirá Zelensky
que juzguen a su amigo? ¿De verdad Ucrania
está lista para acabar con sus élites de
oligarcas y acabar con la corrupción? ¿Es
posible que Ucrania sea rica algún día?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto.